welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday the University of Maryland has
been found culpable in the death of one
of the players on the school's football
team that is one of the findings of an
independent investigation released on
Friday while it provided new details on
what led to 19 year old Jordan McNair's
death the school has not yet taken
further actions against the coaches or
administrators the 74 page report
provides a timeline of the May 29th
football practice that ended up costing
Jordan McNair his life the offensive
lineman collapsed after running a series
of sprints and had to be helped off the
field he was hospitalized with
heatstroke and died two weeks later I
wish we could say that we could bring
Jordan McNair back to life that would be
the greatest thing that we could
possibly do that cannot be done and the
tragedy that the McNair family has set
to deal with cannot be overcome
investigators say more than an hour
passed between the time McNair showed
signs of heat stroke and when team
trainers called 911 the report also
found the trainer's did not follow
proper procedures including using cold
towels and ice packs to try to bring
McNair's body temperature down the
University of Maryland has a good system
in place with staffing of certified
athlete trainers and integration of team
physicians there is a need for better
integration of this service University
of Maryland president Wallace LOH had
already taken what he called legal and
moral responsibility on the day McNair
was hospitalized Lowe says the school
has already begun implementing some of
the changes recommended in the report
including increasing the number of
medical professionals at practices and
games adding more cooling stations at
practices and increasing the length and
frequency of recovery breaks McNair's
death raised questions about Maryland's
football coaching staff head coach DJ
Durkin is on administrative leave while
a separate investigation looks into what
was described in published reports as
abusive behavior by the coaches when you
hear something's preventable it just
feels like such an unnecessary loss it's
very hard to understand how the
university can say they think they have
a good system in place when something
like this can happen just hope we don't
see it again yeah